do you see what our first item is the
emergency evacuation announcement should
we be required to evacuate a building
would you please leave the building by
the nearest available exit there was one
fire exit in this room you need to
graduate if you need a backup room do so
by the glass door just to my left here
doors the fire escape please hold both
10 rounds in case the stairs are wet and
slippery but everybody's unable to use
the stairs we've then please allow
others to exit the room before they go
to the fire escape door and they can be
given assistance now 70 pointings in the
public carpark to the side of the city
suite like that please do not be laying
your evacuation - collecting in the
audience please do not to return to the
building that's given permission by to
do so my council staff please note that
this meeting either will be audio
recorded can i please remind you to
switch off your mobile phone for to turn
on to science quality scratches
not members attending we have counselor
will concerned counselors Farrington
counselor pudding minutes of the meeting
held on 5th of February 2020 receive the
declarations received that is very
interesting you obviously really do come
up to the course for meeting please okay
item five questions on notice fan
counselors counsel will work concerning
here this evening to bring the question
for from a resident council rules
chairman thank you and given that forty
five percent of the district's
population live in railing we are
concerned over the plans for the Civic
suite especially the information point
and the Mill Hall what guarantees are in
places without equivalents facilities so
question chair has come from a resident
within week award
Thank You leader and Thank You the
councillor Wilkinson for the question
which as you say was posed to you by
resident and gives me an opportunity to
respond and firstly can I say that
Rockford district council as a local
authority is required by law to adopt a
highly regulated procurement process
where it is bound by strict rules I'm
grateful to the strategic director who
only last week provided superb training
available to all counselors to help help
them understand the process my
disappointment is that with such a key
project affecting our residents and
businesses not all councillors took the
opportunity to attend had they they
would have realized that despite claims
in media outlets to the contrary
information on the project has not been
behind two closed
doors in fact it has been very open and
in the interest of openness and
transparency at times we push the
regulatory limits there have been many
meetings open to the public to attend as
well as public documents press releases
and frequently asked questions to set
out our plans
additionally the full Alpine business
case has been available on the on the
council's website for everyone to read
the council is pursuing an ambitious
asset asset strategy with the following
objectives to reduce future costs which
must be in the interests of council
taxpayers to regenerate the local area
of facilities for local residents and
businesses and this applies to all over
the Rockford district
so when mention is made of the 45% from
perhaps we might quibble over the
figures but I would have thought 40% was
probably nearer the mark we have to bear
in mind that the other 60% also have to
be taken account of but I do respect
naturally that it becomes from a
questioner in Rayleigh they wish they
obviously have vested interest in in
their own community so to provide the
third point to provide fit for purpose
office accommodation for council staff
from key partners in order to drive
efficiencies through a digital way of
working the asset strategy is just part
of a wider transformation programme on
the way in which this council operates
as portfolio holder for enterprise I
have a clear vision of an optimized
asset base that is fit for purpose
enabling a quality of service delivery
for residents visitors for a sustained
program the transformation from now and
for many years to come
both the Civic suite building and the
mill Arts Center are tired I think we
could all agree with that
I am personally committed to retaining
proportionate civic presence in rating
which will provide facilities to support
residents of the town as well as
touchdown facilities where outreach
officers of the council can meet with
residents at
or from which they can work remotely and
I think that's an important point
unlike 20-30 years ago in theory you
ought to be able to work through current
IT systems almost anywhere and I think
we have to keep focused on that equally
the council is committed to continue to
provide accommodation to its current
community partners Rockford and Roy the
association of voluntary service Reds
open adult counseling services and
citizens of us as well as the groups
clubs and individuals who hire space in
the mill arts and events center for
various important community activities
myself or the member working group have
been clear from the outset that the
civic pride which residents have in our
community facilities their historical
settings and in particular the need for
attractive of modern facilities for
public hire is vital for the design of
any future building this is eliminated
in the output specification that has
been approved by members if the measure
of providing guarantees of what we have
now presumably because of an emotional
attachment to our past or for any other
reason I'm afraid I cannot give you that
I hope the residents and counselors
across the district will share in my
enthusiasm of the vision of the future
in the detail which will be announced
and set out over the coming weeks which
I suggest would be far superior to what
we have now
thank you leader I I did script that
because I was very keen the decent thing
to do when you have a question is to
make sure you cover some clear points
and I was very keen to make sure that I
brought out a wider aspect than just
purely the question itself
and I thank you for giving me the
opportunity to taste like many
Chancellor's and you have one
supplementary question and no I I think
I wouldn't be able to ask
question I thank God to thank counselor
wooden for the answer that he's given
for far exceeds the scope of the
question but I do understand the reasons
why Marge's asked if possible we have
also have a written copy of that
response and that's okay thank you
Thank You chair so the primary business
that the PMO has reported on is
allegedly the Beagle project and it
seems timely to to give members an
update of that we launched the event on
Darwin day on the 12th of February at an
event of the tourism forum to action
hall which was very successful and we
were received quite a lot of national
publicity as a consequence of that
through a social media campaign which we
had orchestrated with the exhibitors who
are part of our event since that launch
we have sold I say sold because the
tickets are free
the we've asked the take-up has been
about 17 percent of the overall
available sales so that's making very
good progress after only three weeks
going live so that's that's really
encouraging the project is well underway
we have a preliminary layout for the
exhibition space and a preliminary
layout for the auditorium running order
as well as the layout of the carpark
area and the green space so as a project
team we're going to sit down and then
just QA that from a health and safety
perspective to make sure that we are in
line with our event management plan and
that we've identified all particular
issues particularly in relation to
equality's and quality of access for
those with restricted mobility the key
output of that plan will of course be
any adjustments that we need to make to
reflect any risks that we've identified
but also it will help us to identify the
number of volunteers that we will
require and the skills and training that
those volunteers will need and where
we're going to station them so that's
the next the next thing that's going to
happen the other thing I've asked in
this report is for the council to to
suspend the parking charges in the back
lane car park for the morning of
Saturday the 30th of May and that's
because it is of course free in an event
on the afternoon and on the Sunday of
that weekend and it seems nonsensical
that people who have come on the
Saturday morning would be penalized and
I'm told by colleagues in parking and
transportation that that would be a loss
of approximately 150 pounds so I hope
that the chair that the members are
amenable to agreeing that question if I
may
we'll also include the parking charges
of yourself there will be no parking at
the freight house on the weekend of the
event that's for self for pedestrian and
sites a few reasons so there are a
limited number of spaces for blue badge
holders and anyone who has a blue but it
wishes to park on the site we've asked
them to contact us directly so that we
can make that available but all other
car drivers will be directed to back
lane and of course will be pushing and
for visitors to use the greater angular
line or public transport Hotel I do I
will have work and I'm just not so I
attended the laundromat was an
exceptionally good morning
as we anticipate and and as soon as we
know what Marshalls etc absolutely we've
already been working with routes to
secure volunteers with general public
and they've already put an advert at
that out for us
they'll be widening that call to arms
amongst members and indeed our own staff
so it'd be nice as soon as the second
point one change 7.1
items 1 1.1 1.2 the 1.3 members happy
with those recommendations is from the
assistant director people use process
World War II voluntary sector in France
so members obviously I'm you say fine to
make the pub you had a chance to read
through that this outlines the work the
year ahead around our volunteer sector
grant program I think there's a local
authority being very fortunate to still
retain and the funding is actually
deliver immigrants programs in the
community and this sets out the plans
for the coming financial year you'll
notice that there's 25,000 pounds being
made available for the property sector
it's been proposed that will be split
with their top slice for grabs and
they'll receive 15,000 pounds and you
turn to 3.4 and they're important
there's a brief outline now for some of
the work so it grabs those community I'm
sure you another fantastic organization
and provide a great service in the
community in terms of the court process
itself
we've got yesterday 33.9 the no
organization plans have bid for more
than one thousand pounds so they're
being kept at a thousand pounds each
organisation and it will be for revenue
funding there'll be no capital funding
made available this year in 3.2 there's
indeed so there on the outcomes that
we're looking for those organizations
that use to apply particular thing to
reduce there was a over whiteness and
obesity to improve mental health and
well-being and just over the page this
is for people to be independent knives
and stay around homes and additionally
found
we allocated squat because demonstrating
how to live homelessness so we will be
looking for advocates to fulfill one or
more of those criteria just draw your
attention to section 3.6 there's the
time frame there for the small grants
process which will be closing on the
10th of April and decision made soon
thereafter we'd also just draw members
attend concede and appendix page 826
where there's a list of the grants
program that was carried out last year
and then you can see the remaining
organizations are benefited from the
community's grants program from across
the district that's an excellent work
one of the things has been for team is
to make sure that the work actually
complements the health more being
strategy which is why there's the column
their well-being action alignment those
numbers actually refer to the points in
the strategy that each of those groups
has helped to means finding members the
remainder of the appendix just highlight
some of the work that they've program
enable to happen there's a maximum work
that's taking place in the community and
through this grants program I'm very
pleased we've been able to continue for
the coming financial year obviously
happy to take any questions just like to
say what's not to like about this report
this is an example of the council
working with the community support and
the community helping
community I think this is another year
of us budgeting some money aside for an
exceptionally good reason and just to
have that there is another avenue of
support that would you give to
organizations by means of the
discretionary rates relief and at some
stage soon there'll be a technical that
indicates the value of that support to
local organizations as well that's just
an addition Italian kids like historic
yeah I take it in addition to the grant
arrives it's not included in the fact
that they actually use these premises is
that over above so it's even greater the
reality okay I believe also be given
free parking spaces don't think you know
German through the kid the application
pool for this feeling okay 11.2 at 1.30
members
is the last item on the agenda thank you
very much for coming along the offices
for their time close the meeting of 19